[拍手]
ずいぶん前の話です
私がある場合に座っていると近くに
ダンディーな男性が座ってました
その話し声がちょっと聞こえてきて
あんま良くないんですけどちょっと耳を
傾けると彼がこう言ってました
結婚っていうのは
1番目に好きな人じゃなくて2番目に好き
な人とするもんだ
と私はなんかなんとかええと思ったんです
けどその男性が非常に
チェロのような低音の声でなんかこう恋愛
25段みたいぐらいのオーラを出してたん
でなんかこう圧倒されてまあそういうもん
なのかなとこう納得したんですけど家帰っ
てみるとやっぱりこう2番手より一番のが
良くないと思い始めてだけどその
男性は知らない人なんでちょっと電話を
かけていやさっきの話なんですけど2番
より一番良くないですかと相談するわけに
はいかない
なのでまあ一人で悶々と考えますずっと
考えてそしてついにですねその答えに
たどり着きましたで本日私はですね皆様に
私たちは編み出したこの一番好きな人と
結婚する方法これを
披露するためにこの場に
やってまいりましたこの手法の優れた
ところは
結婚する前だけじゃなくて
結婚した後にも使える
それさらにはですね簡単な方法なので非常
に単純な方法ですですから
練習もいらずやる気になれば今日から使い
ますでは
一番好きな人と
結婚する方法とは
結婚する人またはした人を一番好きになる
まあただそれだけを単純な話なんですけど
でも単純こそ
究極の宣伝であると言われてますですから
単純を侮ってはいけませんもうちょっと
深く見てみましょうまず
この方法はですね一番好きな人っていうの
には使えますでもこの一番背が高い人と
いうのには使えません
この差は何なのかまず一番好きというのは
自分で決めるんで主体的です
でもこの一番
背が高いっていうのは客観的です
自分が好きっていうのは言い換えれば自分
で決めれるけれど
背が高いっていうのはこう測るんで絶対値
なんで自分で決められないということです
この考え方をまとめた人がフランクリン
交尾博士という人がいますこの
フランクリン交尾博士この人の考えも解い
て実は一番好きというのは
意思決定であるということですだから自分
が決めるでこの考えをフランクリン交尾を
果たすの考えでは世の中っていうのは
たくさんの無関心があります大きな情報が
あって皆さんの
我々も含めてあまりその多くの全部には
興味はないその中でいくつかの興味がある
ことがあるこれを彼は和でくくると関心の
輪と呼びましたその関心の輪の中に
影響の輪があります例えば
監視の罠だったら
景気がどうなるんだとか
過去がどうだとか例えば人の行動誰かが
挨拶をしてくれたとかお菓子をくれたとか
それ以外にも他者の評価好きだとか例えば
SNSでいいねをくれたとかこういった
ものは関心の輪です
しかしこの関心の輪というのは自分で
コントロールできません
一方
影響の輪というのは自分が影響を与える
もの自分の行動であったり
態度であったりそして考え方であったり
こういったものは自分で変えられる
具体的な例で言うと例えば雨が降るという
のは皆さん変えることができませんがその
雨が降った時に
傘を持ってきたとかその雨が降った時に
それを
嬉しいと
悲しいと思うことは皆さんの影響の1の中
がある自分たちが決めれる行動です先ほど
のに戻ってみますと
背が高いというのは関心のまで皆さんが
変えることができませんけれど好きという
のは影響のわに中にあって皆さんが変える
ことができます
ということはこの方法ですね
応用すると今から皆さんがお家に帰って
世界で一番おいしいカレーを食べることも
できますし一番感動する映画を見ることも
できますし当然今日の私の話はですね世界
で一番面白いと思うことも可能なわけです
このフランクリンへ博士はこの自分が変え
られないことに時間を使うより自分が変え
られることに時間を使えば人生は
成功するんだとこの本で説いています
話は変わりますが数年前にこの
YouTubeの広告で
こういったキャッチコピーがありました
好きなことで生きていく非常にキャッチー
で
パワフルで私はこの言葉を聞いた時は
すごくいいキャッチフレーズだなと思った
んですが
実は私はこういう言葉が中高生の時中学生
だった頃高校生だった頃こういう言葉が
すごく嫌いでした
例えばやりたいことをやれとか
夢を持ってとか
その頃は私にはやりたいことも夢も何も
なかったんでそういうことを言われるたび
になんかちょっとずつ
傷ついてました実はやりたいこと
夢がない人に向かってこの好きなことで
生きていくということは非常に残酷な言葉
ですそれはなぜかというといろんなことに
実は興味がなくて
小さな関心の輪しかなくてそして何か問題
が起こると人のせいにしていた主体的に
生きることができなくてこの営業の輪も
非常に小さかったなので私はやりたいこと
を見つけることができませんでした
今日はですね実は皆様に
私から伝えたいのはこの中高生の頃やり
たいことがなかった私は今ある程度のやり
たいことを持って生きているこれをやり
たいことを人生でやるというのをテーマに
お話しさせていただきます
これが本当のテーマです
昔何もなかった自分がどうやって今のよう
になったかそこに何が起こったのか考え方
がどう変わったのかそれをお話しいたし
ます
現在では私はものづくりをする会社に
関わってまして例えばバスケットボールを
作ってますこの2019年に開催された
中国で行われたバスケットボールの
ワールドカップの試合球ゲームで使われる
ボールを作ってこの大会の運営に関わり
ました他には車椅子ユーザーの人に会って
新しい車椅子を作ったりスーパー耐久と
いうレースに車の自動車部品を特別
チューナップした部品を提供することに
よってテクニカルパートナーとして
レースに参加したり
ベンチャーの人と一緒に新しいプロダクト
を開発したりしていますもし誰かが私に
あなたのしたいことは何ですか聞かれたら
私はものづくりで社会を解決したいと
ものづくりで社会の課題を解決したいと
答えます
昔は全然やりたいことがなかったその時に
とにかく本を読んだり人に会ったり旅をし
たり勉強したりしましたでも実はこれを
やってもやりたいことって見つかりません
でした
その代わりに関心の輪は広がりました
いろんなことに
興味を持ちます
そして自分の行動自分の感情っていうのは
自分でコントロールできるんだという意識
を持ったことで主体的に過ごしましたその
ことで
影響の輪が広がりました
それでもやりたいことは見つかりません実
はこのやりたいことというのは自分で
決めるしかないここに気づきましたそれが
すごく些細なことでも
漠然としたことでもいいとにかく
とりあえずこれが自分のやりたいことだと
いうのを決めてこう種のようにちょっと
置くと
それがだんだん大きくなってその漠然とし
たやりたいことはだんだん具体的になり
そしてだんだん大きくなっていく
そういう体験をしたのがこの
我々が進めているプロジェクトマイ
フットボールキットです
いろんな演奏があっていく中で例えば
ソーシャルワーカーだとか
ノンプロフェクトオーガニゼーションの人
とかあとはソーシャルセクターの起業家の
人に会うと世の中っていうのは
経済的な格差や体験格差というのは溢れて
いることを学びましたそして実際に僕らが
カンボジアに行った時にそれを目の当たり
にしました
そこに一緒に行ったメンバーの関心事は
オールが持っていなくてサッカーができ
ないこともたくさんいることを目の当たり
にしたんです
先ほどの関心の後影響の輪に当てはめてい
ます
私たちの私の関心の輪は多くの格差が
世の中あるこれです
それを見つけた時にただそれに対して
嘆いたり
議論したり怒ったりするだけじゃなくて
自分たちができる
影響の輪の中にあるのは何か考えました
一つはまずこの問題に取り組みたいこれを
意思決定しましたそして一人では何もでき
ないので
チームを作ってでその人たちにこの問題
っていうのは取り込む価値があるんだよと
いうことを説明してモチベーションを上げ
てそして我々はものづくりの会社なんで
ビジネスモデルとプロダクトを考えました
これによってどんどん広げていこう
とボールを持ってない子供がいます
その子たちにボールを上げたいんですが実
はボールっていうのは空気が入ってまして
これを使ってると空気がだんだん抜けて
いくそれと多くの人は空気入れというもの
を使ってこう空気を入れるんですけど
じゃあ空気入れというものがボールを持っ
てないと空気量を持っていないだから使っ
てるとどんどん空気が抜けてベコベコの
ボールになっちゃうんですよそうすると
どんどんベコベコになるとも結局も使え
なくなってゴミになって
これは問題だよねということでじゃあ不
機嫌ないんだから空気の抜けないボールを
作ろうということを考えまし
たでも空気っていうのは非常に小さな
粒子なんでこれを閉じ込めておくっていう
のは非常に難しくてしかもそれをある程度
安い値段で作らなきゃいけない広めなきゃ
いけないそうするとかなり至難の技だと
そうするとどうするかっていうと
抜けないんじゃなくてそもそも空気が入っ
てなければ
抜けないよねとじゃあ空気の入ってない
ボールを作ろうという発想の転換があり
ました
でそこでモデルにしたのがタイの競技で
あるセパタクローという
競技ありますそのボールやあとは日本の
縦割りという竹を編んであるものをこう
いう風なボールを作れないかなということ
でエンジニアの人と一緒に試行錯誤した
結果できたのがこのボールキットという
ボールですこれはですねプラスチックの
部品をこう重ね
編むように重ねてそして中は空洞になっ
てるんですけど普通のボールのように
跳ねたり蹴ったりすることができます
実はこのボールが4つの部品からできて
ましてこれがレゴとか
積み木のように子供たちはこのボールを
作ることによって立体感覚は身につくと
特にカンボジアやタイヤ発展途上国の子供
たちは
積み木のようなおもちゃで遊んだことが
ないんでこの日本の子どもたちよりも立体
感覚がないことを教えてもらいましたそう
いったものでこれを作ることによって立体
感覚を養われるという教育的要素も付加
することができた
このプロジェクトはですねただボールを
売るんではなくて世の中にいるボールを
上げたい人たちを見つけてそして僕らが
知ってるこのボールをもらいたい人たちと
これをつないで僕らがこのボールを作って
それをお届けするそういう活動をしてい
ます実際にですねコロナ前にはカンボジア
やタイに行ったり南アフリカに行ったり
そしてコロナへ海外に行けなくなったら
日本国内で
幼稚園やいろんなイベントで子供たちに
こういったボールを
届けてい
ます最初はですすごく小さな関心から
始まったこのプロジェクトですが今は
ボールを持ってない子どもたちに
教育とスポーツで
成長のきっかけを作る空気のいらない
ボールを広く
提供したいこのように大きなやりたいこと
に育っていきました
やりたいことは
意思決定
ですいろんな体験をしていろんな人に会っ
て話をすると関心の輪を広がっていきます
自分の行動や感情これは自分が決めること
ができるそれを知ることで
影響の輪を広げることはできます
ただ
それでもやりたいことは手に入ることが
できません
やりたいことを手に入れる唯一の方法は
自分でこれがやりたいなと決めることです
もし
些細なことでも
小さな粒の自分のやりたいことを見つけて
それを種として
活動していけばそれがいつか大きな花に
なってその花は次第にどんどん増えてき
ます中学生の頃高校生の頃
やりたいことがなかった私は今では
たくさんのやりたいことを
手に入れてそれに向かって進んでいます
それはひとえにこのやりたいことは
意思決定だということに気づいたからです
本日は
私の話を聞いてくれた皆さんと一緒に世界
で一番
楽しい時間を過ごさせていただきました
本日はありがとうございました
[拍手]